en esta ocasión les voy a hablar de algo
llamado eutrofización esta palabra viene
del griego que etimológicamente
significa bien nutrido ee uu
y hace referencia a bien a bueno
mientras que trozos estrofas hace
referencia a nutrición así que tal vez
lo primero que pienses al ver esta
palabra es que es algo bueno pero como
verás en el transcurso del vídeo
este término habla de sobre nutrición
pero en este caso de una sobre nutrición
al punto que causa cosas desagradables a
nuestra biosfera así que la idea general
consiste en hablar de cosas como el
nitrógeno y en especial el fósforo que
es el factor que facilita la tasa de
rapidez con la que crecen las plantas ya
hablamos acerca del nitrógeno en algunos
vídeos sobre el ciclo del fósforo
recuerdas y nosotros los seres humanos
agregamos un montón de nitrógeno y
también en especial fósforo
a las plantas para que crezcan mejor
porque ya saben necesitamos a las
plantas para vivir para obtener comida y
entonces lo que está pasando es lo
siguiente imagina que por aquí tenemos
algún tipo de tierra voy a poner aquí
algún tipo de tierra algo más o menos
así imagínate qué es una granja y en la
granja aquí tenemos un cierto cultivo
déjame poner a este cultivo y bueno aquí
tenemos a unas ciertas plantas así que
las voy a poner con este color tenemos
un montón de plantas así que las voy a
poner este es mi cultivo y bueno a este
cultivo lo que vamos a hacer es ahora
agregarle fertilizante entonces aquí
tengo mi cultivo quiero que crezca lo
más que se pueda y entonces le vamos a
agregar fertilizante entonces déjame
escribirlo a esto le agregamos
fertilizante y bueno tal vez este
fertilizante tenga andrógenos y fósforo
en forma de fosfatos
entonces le añadimos fertilizante y el
mayor culpable de lo que tiene el
fertilizante es justo el fosfato así que
el fósforo por una parte me va a ayudar
a que crezcan un poco más las plantas
para crecer un poco más y más rápido mis
plantas ok pero por otra parte ha dicho
otra manera un efecto secundario de este
fosfato es que el agua para el cultivo
ya sea que provenga de la lluvia o del
riego el agua cuando fluye a través de
los cultivos fluyen a través de estos
cultivos y va bajando hasta llegar no sé
a un arroyo a un río o algún lago va a
llevar un exceso de fertilizante así que
supongamos que este es un lago ok y
ahora como el agua viene llena de
fertilizante entonces este lago va a
tener un montón también de este
fertilizante y en particular de estos
fosfatos así que tenemos un montón de
fosfatos
en este lago y ahora sabemos que aunque
los fosfatos ayudan a que crezcan las
plantas esto también va a ayudar a que
crezcan organismos fotosintéticos como
las algas es decir el lago por sí mismo
ya tiene algas pero ahora si llenas el
lago de fosfatos las algas se van a
volver locas y entonces van a crecer por
toda la superficie del lago y es justo
aquí cuando me refiero a que el alga va
a estar sobre alimentada y esto porque
tendríamos más fosfatos de los que
naturalmente tendríamos sin
fertilizantes y bueno no solamente los
fertilizantes o como también los
detergentes
hay varios detergentes que tienen
fosfatos de sodio que una vez más causan
eutrofización muy bien y ahora
seguramente te vas a preguntar qué tiene
de malo que tengamos aquí a esta
cantidad enormes de algas vas a decir
bueno tal vez el agua se ve un poco más
verde
bueno es un poco menos clara un poco
menos translúcida pero bueno aquí
tenemos un montón de organismos viviendo
que puede estar mal pero el problema
viene cuando todas estas algas mueren
porque cuando todas estas algas mueren
empiezan a sumergirse van a empezar a
sumergirse adentro de este lago ok
sus cadáveres van a caer y luego lo que
pasa es lo siguiente las bacterias que
están en el lago comen estas algas estas
algas muertas pero si las bacterias
empiezan a consumir un montón de algas
bueno empieza a ver un montón de
bacterias en este lago y estas bacterias
también consumen oxígeno y que hemos
hablado de la importancia del oxígeno en
la respiración
entonces las bacterias van a consumir
todo el oxígeno del lago y ahora bien
cuando pensamos en animales que habitan
el lago o el océano déjame poner por
aquí la superficie de este lago y voy a
poner por aquí a algo
animal no sé se me ocurre un pez voy a
dibujar por aquí un pez que esté bien
feliz en este lago aquí está mi peso y
está bien feliz en este lago bueno este
pez necesita oxígeno de la misma manera
que nosotros para poder vivir y los
peces no obtienen el oxígeno cuando las
olas rompen o cuando hay una cascada y
entonces entra el oxígeno al agua y es
justo así que estos animales marinos
pueden vivir pueden respirar ahora así
tenemos por aquí a nuestras bacterias y
todas estas bacterias están consumiendo
el oxígeno del agua para poder
descomponer a toda la cantidad de algas
que cayeron al morir y recuerdan toda
esta alga muerta no se produjo por los
fosfatos entonces lo único que va a
pasar es que estos animales marinos ya
no van a poder vivir aquí se van a morir
y la ironía aquí es que por querer
fertilizar este cultivo para que crezcan
más rápido
los fosfatos hacen la eutrofización lo
cual está haciendo que crezcan más un
organismo que otro y en este caso eso
nos lleva a que se consuma el oxígeno
del agua que ayuda a otros organismos a
crecer y esto es lo que generan es lo
que llamamos una zona muerta así que
este pez va a morir y aquí se va a
generar una zona
déjame escribirlo
y esto porque no tenemos el suficiente
oxígeno y estas zonas muertas son un
problema serio aquí hay algunas
fotografías
en esta primera tenemos una zona muerta
por eutrofización y si muevo la pantalla
por aquí puedes ver otra y probablemente
has visto algo así sobre todo en lugares
donde desemboca el drenaje de aguas
residuales o algo así y realmente no se
ve así porque tenemos un exceso de
nutrientes que hacen que estas algas
eclosionen y se salga de control así que
cuando mueren estas algas las bacterias
las consumen junto con eso consumen el
oxígeno y al final nada más puede vivir
ahí y esto está pasando también a una
escala macroscópica y ahora miran por
acá tengo otra ilustración donde vas a
poder ver todas las zonas en el mundo
que tienen eutrofización y puedes ver
que en general se encuentran en las
zonas donde hay más industrias en las
zonas donde hay una mayor cantidad de
agricultura y sobre todo una mayor
cantidad de industrias
agrícola donde obviamente usan más
fertilizantes y esto hace que además
desde las ciudades se manden todos estos
fosfatos que causan eutrofización y si
ahora nos fijamos por aquí y podemos ver
que este es el mar caspio y le hacemos
un acercamiento lo puedes ver justo aquí
esta es una imagen que ha sido tomada
por un satélite y en ella puedes ver que
hay eutrofización justo aquí toda esta
zona donde tenemos un color más verde en
esta zona y esta zona de acá tiene
eutrofización observa que el agua se ve
de un color distinto y bueno este es un
problema ecológico muy grave en el cual
tenemos que pensar en un nivel los
fosfatos y los fertilizantes y los
nitratos se ven como algo bueno algo que
nos ayuda con nuestros cultivos pero hay
que tener mucho cuidado en donde
realmente van a terminar